I wanted to point out a couple things do
you notice how guys that are more blue
pill always use partner in their
language because again they're at a more
egalitarian model we are equal like that
that is their mindset yeah I really
think I was trying to think of a similar
equivalent of a woman going to a club
and I was thinking maybe a man on a
dating app but even that is the same
because again you're putting a girl in a
situation where men like you're
basically saying go to this club where
50 men are gonna try to sleep with you
at the same time why do women feel
entitled to acting the same way in a
relationship as you do single